in for honor nights Vikings and samurai  fight to control territory in a  persistent cross-platform war join your  faction in battle claim new lands and  tip the scales of war in your favor will  you serve the Knights and fight with  valor  [Music]  will you unite with a samurai and strike  with deadly elegance  or will you side with the Vikings and  their thirst for battle  choose your faction lead your army into  battle  and claimed victory to reach the spoils  of war  this is not a world to be shared it is a  world to be taken  or path to faction victory  is not carved in stone it is paid in  blood  sign up for the closed beta on january  twenty sixth